the 70 billion pound government furlough
program ends today so what next for more
than one and a half million workers who
are still relying on the scheme for
financial support with the 20 pound a
week universal credit uplift also
finishing in the next few days and a
warning of higher fuel bills there are
renewed concerns that millions will
struggle to make ends meet this winter
we'll speak to the chief secretary to
the treasury simon clark very shortly
also this morning for you the labour
leader so kirstjarma will be here fresh
from his first in-person speech to his
party conference that's at 8 45 and
i started
[Music]
that's your ear worm for today ladies
and gentlemen mr american pie himself
don mclean will be chatting to us about
his new tour that's at a quarter to 10.
it's thursday the 30th of september
volo finishes an uncertain future for
more than a million british workers as
the government ends the scheme along
with other coveted support measures
with concerns about the end of the
universal credit uplift rising gas bills
i'll be examining what the government
plans to do to help poor households this
winter
the murder of sarah everard her killer
wayne cousins could be handed a whole
life term when he's sentenced this
morning
after 13 years britney spears wins
freedom from her father and what a judge
here called a toxic environment
building bridges kim jong-un seeks to
restore cross-border communication
hotlines between north and south korea
new measures to ease the fuel crisis the
government rolls out its reserve tankers
and reports that petrol is being
diverted from large firms to filling
stations
i'm in la palma where residents are
still being told to stay inside because
of toxic gas fears after lava from the
volcano made its way to the sea
and the weather feeling autumnal with
wet and windy spells
[Music]
morning everybody the furlough scheme
introduced to stop millions of people
from losing their jobs during the
pandemic ends today unions are warning
it will lead to major unemployment with
other coveted support schemes also
coming to an end
the government says at its peak the
fellow program protected
11.6 million jobs the end of july 1.6
million people were still on furlough
and it's feared the end of the scheme
may lead to a spike in unemployment the
cost of the program so far has been
68 billion pounds the 20 pound a week
universal credit uplift will also go
between now and the 6th of october and
it's the last day for the stamp duty cut
on homes costing up to 250 000 pounds
which helped keep the housing market
afloat
and it's also the end for the temporary
cut in v8 from 20 to 5
for the tourism and hospitality
industries our business correspondent
helen smith reports
in the shadow of flight paths on the
perimeter of airports just some of the
places where you'll find workers for
whom life just got that little bit more
uncertain
miguel is one of them he works for a
handling firm at heathrow he's been on
either furlough or flexi furlough for
the entire pandemic although his job has
survived his hours and pay have been
significantly cut back
it's been very strange the fact of in
the beginning being paid to be at home
in the beginning it may sound like a
dream idea for some people but in my
case i i love my job the stress of
knowing whether there will be jobs
available or not has been always the
main
worry
for many here that uncertainty will feel
familiar 1.6 million people were still
on furlough this summer it's unclear how
many of those jobs will survive
sky news analysis has found that there
are 18 local authorities with over 8
percent of people still on furlough as
of mid-august
of these 11 are also in the top 10 of
areas with the highest universal credit
claimants
one of them is here in hounslow west
london it has the highest furlough rate
in the country and the fifth highest
claimant count
at the hope church there's a sense
they're bracing an already squeezed
community they say now faces a spiraling
cost of living and no safety net
there's a lot of low paid
labor here so um it's it's been really
hard for them to
find other jobs that will pay enough for
them to be able to live and the furlough
scheme has
helped but it's only gone so far
the furlough scheme in particular was
unprecedented and it's no doubt saved
millions of jobs in tens of thousands of
companies and has kept unemployment
relatively low but the impacts will be
felt for a long time in communities like
this in terms of the cost
tens of billions of pounds that will
need to be paid back probably through
higher taxes or lower spending
and for some it's already too late
claire is a single mum and was
furloughed from her job as a travel
agent but she was ultimately let go and
relies on the now reduced universal
credit
all of a sudden you have to
cut things short and just say
no i need to do this i need to stop that
i can't have this luxury this month
you don't mean having to tell your kids
that they can't get something because
you've no money it's ridiculous
the government never said it could or
should save every job and it certainly
saved many but for some emerging from a
transformative scheme into a transformed
economy they still face a winter packed
with problems
helen and smith sky news in hanslow
chief secretary to the treasury simon
clark is with us now hello to you thanks
for joining us on the program morning
morning furlough ends today what happens
next well this is a real milestone i
think in our journey out of the kovit
pandemic so yes you're right this is the
the last day of the furlough scheme
which has been a huge success in
protecting jobs from 8.9 million at the
peak to just 1.6 million now on the
scheme today many of whom are on what's
flexible for though that is to say
they're working a bit and they're on
furlough a bit so this has been a huge
success in making sure that this awful
situation hasn't cost millions of jobs
which would have been the the central
estimate when this all began so we think
two million fewer people are unemployed
as a result of further having been in
place than uh would have otherwise been
the case so this is a really big day i
think but also it's a moment where we
can start to renormalize the economy and
start to actually get back to a more
flexible labor market obviously ease the
enormous burden on the taxpayer which
has been caused by this pandemic and
actually look ahead now to a much more
uh bright bright future because the
employment situation is now really
strong what happens to those 1.6 million
people well
we're in a situation now where obviously
they will be talking to their employers
we've got over a million vacancies in
the labor market at this point which is
fantastic and we've now actually got
more people on payroll than we had
before the pandemics so there is a lot
of opportunity out there now for people
and
there's never if you like an easy moment
to end these measures because they are
you know they've been hugely important
but it is also time i think to recognize
that we are now thankfully out of the
teeth of this pandemic the vaccine
programs work brilliantly and we're in a
situation where normal opportunities
back out there for people to embrace so
what happens to those 1.6 million people
well they will be talking to their
employers and there'll be a range of
outcomes frankly we never said that we
could protect every job as part of this
the pandemic is that some people will
lose their jobs i i think i think we
have to be totally honest about this the
covert pandemic you know has taken a
toll on our economy it's changed some
things obviously there will be new
opportunities as well and as i say
there's a million vacancies in the
labour market at the moment which is
absolutely brilliant and we've got uh
you know the the unemployment rate is
now back down to 4.6 percent it's fallen
for seven months in a row my message to
anyone out there who's worried would be
that there are these opportunities there
that obviously there's a huge range of
support from government uh the kickstart
scheme for young people a restart scheme
for people who want uh to upskill in in
mid-life and i think you know this is
absolutely a time where people should be
reassured that both the support is there
and the opportunities are there for them
to move forward now with purpose of
those 1.6 million people you know
realistically how many do you think will
be without a job well it's impossible to
put an estimate i don't have objections
well
obviously there will be a variety of
outcomes from this situation i don't i
don't have an estimate with me today the
point is that obviously there will be
some some job losses but there are also
as i say this million vacancies in the
labor market for people uh to move
towards and a huge range of support to
help them do that furlough has protected
uh 11.6 million jobs in total during the
course of its time at some point you
have to end these emergency measures
they are uh extraordinary and they're
extraordinary for a reason you have to
have a labor market where uh there are
you know there is there is change
frankly and people's jobs will be
created just as some have very sadly
been lost and that is that is part of
the process of ending this crisis and
going back to normal yeah i mean i'm not
very good at maths but you say there's a
million uh roles available opportunities
available there's 1.6 million people on
follow that means 600 000 people no well
many of the people who are still on fuel
are on what's called flexible furloughs
so they're effectively they've been
doing some hours but maybe less than
they would otherwise have been doing and
so it's not it's not as simple as saying
there's 1.6 million and therefore they
will lose their jobs it's much much more
nuanced than that and
you know there's there's a huge range of
support as i say to to help people out
there to make these transitions and that
is that's really a core message today
that you are not alone in this situation
just as frankly the government has
ensured that nobody's alone through
covid that we have made sure that
furlough's been in place to support the
economy protect jobs and as i say the
fact that we can end this is a great
success really it means that the scheme
has done its job and we're now in a
situation where people can look forward
to you know returning to normal which is
what we all want to do i suppose keeping
um universal credit would help well the
universal credit uplift was always
intended as a very specific response to
the pandemic just as furlough was
reflecting the fact obviously people
couldn't work or couldn't work the same
number of hours in many cases and that
they had higher fixed costs for example
with
food being delivered as opposed meal to
go to the supermarket
we are today uh introducing this uh a
new scheme which is the the household
support fund and this is intended to
make sure that
uh we can help three to four million uh
of the lower earning families in england
with with the cost of living and that
will be predominantly focused on food
and utilities distributed through
councils worth an average of a hundred
pounds each that's designed just to help
with the cost of living pressures
throughout the winter that's ahead
universal credit is not the right
response to to this situation it's worth
reminding viewers that had we maintained
this uplift we've been talking the
equivalent of a penny on income tax and
three peon fuel duties to sustain it
it's an enormously expensive mechanism
this is a very targeted response the new
household support fund designed to help
the lowest earning families throughout
the winter ahead and that is obviously
something which i think people will
welcome uh to make sure that every
family can you know get through this
winter successfully and safely it sounds
like a universal credit by another name
no as i say it's it's it's targeted at
the lowest earning families
universal credit is a broader mechanism
it supports both people who are out of
work and in work uh this is something
which is designed as i say to catch the
most vulnerable households who are
facing uh obviously the costs of living
you know in the way which we all want to
make sure that people can can support uh
so this is this is a different mechanism
more more targeted and as i say it
avoids the situation while putting up
everyone's taxes to pay for an extension
of universal credit which would frankly
be unaffordable uh the business
secretary quasi qartong said yesterday
he's not guaranteeing anything when it
comes to the potential impact
of the fuel crisis um and also the
energy crisis leading up to
christmas um is that really the best you
can do well we're in a situation now
where the the fuel crisis thankfully is
easing i think one of the key messages
i'd want to get across this morning is
that if people just return to normal
buying habits we are in a situation now
where more fuel is being delivered to
petrol stations than is being sold so
that crisis is now
absolutely
something which is back under control
and that is something which will
continue to ease if people just uh
return to normal buying habits we've got
a range of measures in place to help
with the cost of living uh when it comes
to energy costs obviously we've got the
energy price cap we also have the warm
home discount for lower earning families
and pensioners get their cold weather
payments as well which will be paid
through in october and november for them
the government's doing a lot of work in
this space to help support families with
the cost of living there's been
additional help council tax support
increases to the local housing allowance
we understand that obviously there are
some squeezes in terms of key prices and
we understand that we need to make sure
that families are supported anecdotally
my um my producer mike tells me that he
drove past 10 um fuel stations this
morning none of them had any fuel well i
think
we are now in a situation where the data
is becoming much clearer on this and
whereas at the weekend 60 of petrol
stations were out of fuel that was down
to 27 percent as of yesterday so the
number one quarter the numbers are
really moving in the right direction
obviously we are we're confident that
that situation will continue to improve
has the army been involved at all well
we have 150 drivers on standby to help
have they been used at all they haven't
yet been used but they are on standby to
help the the most important message
though is that actually the resilience
of the fuel supply chain is now
improving
minister
if there's still a quarter of um fuel um
petrol forecasts that don't have fuel
and you've got the army on standby why
don't you use them well
they are ready to help if they are
needed we are confident that on the
basis that we're getting
whereas at the weekend it was 60 percent
of stations that didn't have fuel that's
now down to 27 percent and falling as i
say more fuel has now been delivered to
petrol stations and sold we're confident
that the commercial market can resolve
this we stand by obviously if we need to
intervene to act but equally the main
message today is there is enough fuel i
understand why people are unnerved by
some of the scenes they've seen at
petrol stations but if people just shot
normally this will very quickly correct
itself and i suppose if you've got 100
000 more lorry drivers well we're in a
situation obviously where we need to
resolve what is an hgv shortage hgg hgv
driver shortage across the continent
yeah but we don't care the ministers
always say this
my viewers this morning don't care
what's happening in portugal don't care
what's happening in germany don't care
what's happening in poland they want
fuel to get to work and they've got a
problem with getting food in their
supermarkets because we don't have
enough larry as we all do but some of
the coverage would suggest that this is
a uniquely british challenge it isn't
the end the industry faces uh quite
quite a challenge with its workforce
profile so it's an aging
workforce the hgv driver workforce and
obviously that's been exacerbated by
some of the kovid challenges yeah we are
working flat out to make sure that we
train more drivers that we increase
testing capabilities so we can actually
make sure they pass their driving test
54 000 applications still waiting at the
dvla and of those only about 4 000 are
actually applications for new licenses
the majority are for renewals and we're
and people can still drive while those
are pending so it's important that
we we contextualize that that only a
tiny minority of those are actually new
provisional licenses and the turnaround
time for those is five days and we're
working to bring that down to even less
that's interesting um
talk to me about what on earth is going
on with the story that's on a lot of the
front pages this morning sarah everard
wayne cousins
how do we possibly
get young women particularly to trust
the police again it's
an appalling story and you know it's
something which i think has genuinely
shocked all of us and
uh you know i'm roughly sarah's age and
it strikes me that it's it is one of
those ones which will remain with us for
a generation
it is so important i think to emphasize
that wayne cousins who is a monster does
not represent the the work of
all those tens of thousands of policemen
and women who go out every day to keep
us safe
the government's got a new strategy in
place to counter violence against women
and girls we recognize that this is a
profoundly important issue and one where
reassurance supporting survivors helping
victims is something which you know is
at the heart of our work we've brought
in a new domestic abuse out this year
we've brought in stalking protection
orders we recognized that there is a lot
of work to be done in this space and
obviously it's something which the home
office is working very very hard on as
of course as the metropolitan police to
restore that confidence after this
really awful event but he was a serving
police officer
did they do enough checks to get before
people are uh allowed to be police well
he will have been subject to all the
checks which uh still he got through
well indeed and i think i think that the
the reality is that no system can
complete the guard against someone doing
what uh mr cousins did he uh well
obviously
later today i'll be the sentencing and i
it reflects the fact that what he
what he did was was monstrous uh and i
think beyond anyone's ability to really
have foreseen and you know in so far as
there are lessons to be learned i know
the metropolitan things we're looking at
really very seriously mister thank you
for taking the time to join us this
morning we really appreciate it thank
you
still to come on the program for you
this morning as the government deploys
its reserve fleet of tankers amid the
fuel crisis
um we'll be speaking to a former adviser
to the government and their supply team
particularly fuel supply that's at half
past seven seven forty we'll speak to
the owner of a hotel in cumbria about
what the end of the furlough scheme
means for her and her industry
[Music]
and off the back of his first in-person
address to his party as labour leader
speaking to sakia stammer joining us
here in the studio
just talking there with the minister
about the police officer wayne cousins
who murdered sarah everard after
kidnapping her as she walked home
in south london he's going to be
sentenced at the old bailey this morning
yesterday the court heard how cousins
used coveted lockdown regulations to
falsely arrest miss everard before he
kidnapped raped and then murdered her
images seen at the old bailly showed ms
everard talking to her killer moments
before he abducted her
in statements read at the sentencing
hearing sarah's parents said they would
never forgive her killer her mother
susan said she was tormented at the
thoughts of what her daughter endured
haunted by the horror of it and outraged
at the thought of cousins masquerading
as a police officer while her father
jeremy demanded sarah's kill looked at
him in his face as he read his statement
saying no punishment for cousins would
ever compare to the pain and torture
inflicted on their family
i think it's got to be at some stage
when she's realized
wait a minute where are we going you
know he's heading towards dover so
there's got to be something happening
between
london and dover where
and her feeling completely powerless
yes i mean being handcuffed obviously as
we know is
you know it is restrictive he doesn't
hold the same values as a police officer
he doesn't have the same personality
that we do you know he's a very sick
and very dangerous individual who should
never have been near a uniform
as we were saying we will hear what the
tariff is for his time in prison later
on today martin brunt our crime
correspondent bringing that to us from
about nine o'clock this morning meantime
britney spears father has been suspended
from the pop stars conservatorship a
judge in the u.s said that jamie spears
remaining in charge of his daughter's
estate was untenable as our u.s
correspondent greg milan reports
when i say free you say brady it's a
movement that's grown big enough to
close down the street outside of court a
noisy campaign on behalf of a superstar
they say deserves her freedom
and this the moment they've been waiting
for
they heard those cheers inside court as
jamie spears was removed as conservator
of his daughter's life after 13 years
[Music]
the singer had told the court in june
that she felt abused and humiliated
three months on the judge ruled in her
favor citing what she said had become a
toxic environment
brittany marked the moment by posting a
video of her flying a plane on cloud
nine she wrote her lawyer declared it a
victory
mr roosevelt just how big a day is this
do you think it's a monumental day for
brittany
it's a monumental day in a monumental
step toward
justice i believe so
and for friends from her past it was
emotional today i bet you she's
liberated
there's going to be a lot of crying
there's going to be a lot of like oh my
god it is like you know the five stages
of grief she's going to be going through
this because now that her father's
finally out of her life she's able to
finally be free
and that's what everybody needs to focus
on is her freedom
so she can get back to being her
it's likely the conservatorship will end
for good within months but the rumors
and allegations could mean years of
court battles
for most of the last 13 years it was
only really the dedicated britney spears
fan who was tuning in to what was
happening in her life but the remarkable
developments of the last three months
will have a significance far beyond just
her story
especially those also subject to
conservatorships
it is an important day because all too
often conservatives are ignored and
their wishes are ignored and their lives
are ignored when you become a
conservative in los angeles they
sometimes call it legal death
for her fans this fight isn't over for
britney spears this is the moment that
she to use her phrase got her life back
greg milam sky news los
angeles at home the government's
deployed its reserve fleet of 80
government-owned tankers to get fuel to
petrol stations at the moment they're
being driven by civilians but the army
will also be helping to get supplies to
where they are needed in coming days in
some parts of the country bus services
have been cut back to ensure there is
enough petrol to get children to school
more than a quarter of petrol stations
are still out of fuel but the industry
says that the shortages are easing
a study suggested that giving children
two doses of a coronavirus vaccine could
potentially prevent thousands of cases
of long covid researchers at queen mary
university of london carried out a study
to assess the double dosing of children
aged 12-17
they say the benefits of giving children
two doses outweigh the risks
pupils taking exams in england next year
will be given advance notice on the
focus of exam papers and more lenient
grading than before the pandemic to make
up for disruption the government has
confirmed students will be offered exam
aids and a choice of topics in some
exams during the 2022 period
northern korea leader kim jong-un has
offered to restore communication
channels with south korea several months
after pyongyang stopped replying to
messages from seoul so what's going on
our asia correspondent tom cheshire
standing by for us now hello to you um
tom uh north korea once again in the
headlines this week
yeah morning k um it has been a busy
week a busy time for north korea only
this week they said they developed a new
hypersonic uh missile system uh which
would be their fastest missile they have
in their arsenal but this is different
this is an olive branch from north to
south we've seen the south korean
president moon jae-in
at his address to the united nations
general assembly called it called for an
end to the korean war which has never
formally ended uh and we've seen a bit
more uh nice words from north korea in
return at the same time they did say
that south korea was a slave to the us
but this is an indication they want to
get something moving while moon jae-in
is still in power he'll be out of office
next year and the next uh president may
not be so willing to help things along
in terms of the peace process on the
korean peninsula on the other hand there
was scathing about the united states
saying that the united states offer of
diplomacy uh was just a trick that it
was cunning that it wasn't a real thing
but at the same time they haven't gone
uh further with their testing you might
remember there's been a lot of activity
recently that cruise missile mentioned
but also other ballistic missile tests
the un has said they've restarted their
nuclear reactor so potentially producing
fuel for nuclear weapons but what they
haven't done is fired a long-range
intercontinental ballistic missile the
sort that could reach the united states
itself that has been a moratorium for a
long time now because it really is the
u.s red line and i think the north
koreans have been waiting to see what
the administration of joe biden
president biden is going to do in
regards to north korea but they are
making a lot more noise because they
want to be reminding the world that
they're still here this problem still
hasn't been resolved uh the united
nations security council is actually
meeting today behind closed doors to
discuss what to do with north korea but
this is north korea trying to move
things along and remind the world that
they're still here they still have these
weapons and there's still not a solution
on the korean peninsula okay thanks very
much tom thank you
uh people have been told to stay indoors
after lava from the volcanic eruption on
the canary islands reach the atlantic
ocean releasing huge plumes of steam and
possibly toxic gas thousands have
already been evacuated as people living
nearby are told to stay away from the
fumes
these are some of the latest images of
the volcano from overnight pretty
dramatic aren't they it's been erupting
now for 10 days with warnings it could
go on for many months to come becky uh
standing by for us on the island hello
to becky still incredibly dramatic
pictures this morning good morning
morning k yes you can see there's still
uh huge fountains of lava coming out of
the side of volcano that's from the
vents that have opened up in the side of
the volcano to release that molten rock
and still flowing down to the sea as you
mentioned residents being told to stay
inside when the lava hits the sea the
toxic gas it releases contains
hydrochloric acid that is dangerous to
breathe in and dangerous to get in your
eyes now in reality
uh things have actually worked out
better than people thought they might
the government has said the air quality
is still good and the wind i don't if
you can tell it's very windy is blowing
in the right direction it's blowing the
gas out to sea and we were speaking to
residents in tassakorte that's the area
around the coast where they are supposed
to be indoors yesterday they actually
aren't that concerned about the gas what
is getting to them is is that this has
been going on now for 11 days this
volcano has been erupting and they are
fed up their kids aren't in school many
of them aren't going to work
everything's been disrupted and they
just want life to return to normal
thank you
a quick look at what's happening as far
as the weather's concerned here wet and
windy spells will make it feel very
autumnal over the next few days could
turn stormy this weekend
now something to make you think twice
about living next to a lake in america
what on earth is she talking about well
a lone alligator over here actually
alone alligator decided he'd explore his
florida neighborhood
a bit
and gave residents quite a fright the
man seen in this video managed to trap
the reptile
in a bin
before letting it free
into a nearby lake what have you got in
that bin not telling you uh alligator
encounters are not uncommon in the state
with the fish and wildlife conservation
commissioner estimating there's one
alligator for every
15 residents
get out of that bin
and make it snappy we'll speak to a
former adviser to the government's fuel
supply team coming up very shortly as it
deploys its reserve fleet of tankers to
get petrol supplies out to consumers
[Music]
again everybody the furlough scheme
introduced to stop millions of people
from losing their jobs during the
pandemic ends
today unions are warning it will lead to
major unemployment with other coveted
support schemes also coming to an end
currently about 1.6 million people on
furlough so earlier i asked the chief
secretary to the treasury simon clark
how many job losses there would be
it's it's impossible to put an estimate
i don't have objections well
obviously there will be a variety of
outcomes from this situation i don't i
don't have an estimate with me today the
point is that obviously there will be
some some job losses but there are also
as i say this million vacancies in the
labour market for people uh to move
towards and a huge range of support to
help them do that furlough has protected
uh 11.6 million jobs in total during the
course of its time at some point you
have to end these emergency measures
they are uh extraordinary and they're
extraordinary for a reason you have to
have a labor market where uh there are
you know there is there is change
frankly and people's jobs will be
created just as some have very sadly
been lost and that is that is part of
the process of ending this crisis and
going back to normal
ali's here this morning good morning so
1.6 million people on fellow a million
jobs are available not that hard to do
the maths is it yeah and i thought it
was interesting to hear
simon clark himself there saying that
there will be job losses but as you said
there are warnings that we could see a
rise in unemployment he spoke about this
half a billion
pound fund that's going to help as he
put it the most vulnerable people still
waiting for the details of that really
trying to work out exactly what they
mean by the most vulnerable people
that's going to help with things like
food clothing utilities but i think you
know the fact that that that exists now
gives us a sense of where we are really
because of course you know there have
been these warnings about the wider
context another winter discontent either
this sort of cost of living crisis with
the high energy bills with people
queuing at fuel stations the end of the
universal credit uplift is this creating
you know the perfect storm to make life
really difficult for some families this
autumn
um indeed we also interestingly talked
about sarah everard didn't he and his
comments about wayne cousins was strong
really strong yeah he said he described
wayne cousins as a monster and he said
that this is something that the home
office are dedicated to tackling but i
think you know they are facing more
position now perhaps from labour who
yesterday the kirstarma the labour lead
i think made very clear in his speech
that he wants crime to be front and
center of his campaign and that is you
know perhaps a new change of stance from
labour um so it'd be interesting to see
if they face more position from from the
the labour party on that okay ali for
now thanks very much indeed thank you
ali
uh there is also a warning that there
are dark days ahead in northern ireland
with energy bills set to rise sharply
this winter in some areas gas prices
will go up by as much as 35 percent from
next month prompting warnings that
people will simply self-disconnect
charities fear more people will be
plunged into fuel poverty and be unable
to heat their homes becky johnson
reports
in northern ireland the perfect storm is
brewing the end of furlough and removal
of the universal credit uplift happening
at the same time as a huge increase in
gas prices
from tomorrow people will be charged up
to 35 percent more many don't know how
they'll afford it victoria mcclements is
a mother of two who works in a special
needs school scared scared i'm going to
be able to hit my house so i'm going to
keep like she would go to bed with her
like her room would be the coldest room
in our house and she goes to be able to
hot water bottles and fleecy blankets
sometimes i've done without food to eat
nice so i have kids are fed i would do
without a dinner so that dinner was put
into the heating
like victoria the majority of gas
consumers in northern ireland use
pay-as-you-go meters
she knows what happens when the money
runs out it's happened a couple of times
like when she's about to get a shower
and it's raining i've had no money and
there's no emergency on it it's
you haven't
you can't show your kids you can't wash
your dishes
so you can't because your gas is your
main heating hot water supply campaign
gas camping electric before the price
rises people have been keen to top up
there's just been a lot of customers
coming in topping up their gas because
they're panicking due to the increase
and a lot of them just were through
covert they just don't have much money
at the minute
among them lorraine whose job in a care
home pays barely enough to cover the
bills
her husband has cancer but they have to
ration the heating
well just leave it off during the day
and put it on at night
you know because you couldn't afford to
burn it during the day
but even though you can't you know
before it goes up you don't really have
it on during the day every penny yarn is
just going in food and bills and you've
nothing left over
you know so you're just really getting
by from month to month around a quarter
of homes in northern ireland rely on gas
and there's no energy price cap here
instead a regulator controls prices
it blames the record increase in global
costs that will now be felt in thousands
of homes there's a fear some will simply
switch their gas off altogether no
longer able to afford to heat their
homes people can self-disconnect very
quickly
these eye watering
increases to the gas prices and indeed
to oil where we have 68 households
reliant on home heating oil there are
dark days ahead and we need an urgent
intervention from government to assist
low-income households
families who are facing the prospect of
a long cold winter becky johnson sky
news belfast
analyst uh joe armitage um hi joe thanks
for joining us what has caused this
issue
well the increase in general energy
prices is set by multiple different
factors some of them are international
and you saw recently that the price of
gas the price of uh gas increased
because you had a lack of wind
which the uk is particularly reliant on
at certain points and indeed you have to
see the switching on of coal power
stations which is quite expensive and so
ultimately the gas price was elevated
and unfortunately it seems that it will
be elevated for some period of time
and what can we
blame the fuel crisis on
well i think that the fuel crisis is is
somewhat of a an idiosyncratic situation
because you had this this essential run
on petrol stations caused by uh some
briefing in relation to a situation that
was actually incredibly minor you know a
very small number of petrol stations ran
out of fuel
and that was in a few regions and
ultimately the reporting of that
situation led to a run on petrol
stations and i think that that was
primarily the cause but the underlying
cause of the petrol stations running out
in in a very small number of areas was
this lack of htv drivers that has been
afflicting many different sectors
because ultimately the economy was
turned off uh in many sectors uh for the
pandemic and it's just been turned back
on and some sectors are emerging that
are far bigger than they were before and
those sectors happen to employ a lot of
hgv drivers for example and so sectors
are competing to retain and recruit htv
drivers and this is elevating prices and
making it difficult to deliver goods
suspending competition law apparently to
try to fix this that's what the
government announced what does that
actually mean
well in practice what this means is that
companies within the downstream oil
industry are able to share information
about where they've got bottlenecks
where they've got problems supplying the
regions they're responsible for and so
if companies are able to see where
deliveries are needed because demand has
increased in particular reach and
applicable then they're able to share
that information
and get the deliveries to where it needs
to be in a way that's not ordinarily
allowed by the competition act because
companies don't ordinarily share you
know commercially sensitive information
so this measure it seems like it's
already helping because if you look at
the information released
by the petrol retailers association
overnight you've seen actually the
situation at the weekend was that 60
of petrol stations were running out of
fuel and yesterday it was under 30 so
the situation is improving very rapidly
and i might say that's without the use
of military drivers at this point
how confident are you feeling uh in the
run-up to christmas on both uh fuel hdv
drivers um and indeed people being able
to heat their homes properly
well i think there are multiple
challenges uh and i know that the
government has increased its resources
and it's got you know a team of people
in multiple different sectors looking at
these issues and looking at the data
that comes in relation to them so they
can advance response mechanisms like
we've seen with the downstream oil
sector so i think you know i would be
confident in the robust nature of the
measures that the government's got in
its locker to deploy if necessary but
obviously there are very wide issues and
they're international in nature you know
affecting many different countries
because as i say the economy was turned
off in many sectors it's being turned
back on and the new economy is very
different to the economy that we exited
so it's very difficult to be confident
because there are black swan events that
can come about you know human nature
will play a big role and that's very
unpredictable but i think we can be
confident that there are measures to
deploy if necessary uh and the situation
hopefully uh we're already seeing it
improve in certain ways you know with
the downtrend sector the co2 issue seems
to have been resolved you know it looks
like the situation has been tackled
quickly with respect to those issues so
if anything comes around the corner
hopefully that can be got on top of
quickly as well
love a bit of positivity on a thursday
morning good to talk to you thanks very
much
thank you thank you
afraid i'm going to have to talk about
the furlough scheme now though which was
introduced
originally to stop millions of people
from losing their jobs during the
pandemic it ends today there are fears
it could create poverty and unemployment
with other coveted support measures
coming to an end
as well joining us now is kate ridding
owner of the orange tree hotel in kirby
she was with us earlier in the year
kirby lonsdale of course um kate hello
to you we talked to you earlier in the
year and you were telling me about how
tricky it was to get hold of staff and
how important the um
that the scheme had been for you the
furlough scheme for you and your staff
where are you today
um we're in yeah a bit of a mess really
we the staffing issues uh just got so
much worse and all our students left to
go back to uni and that's now left us
with just four key staff that are
working um seven days a week
and
there's pubs in our area that are now
shutting midweek and they're only
opening thursday friday saturday sunday
and the customs there the the people are
still coming the
holiday lights are full our bedrooms are
full everywhere is still full people are
out spending they're still out going on
holiday
but people can't provide the service
because we have no staff to do that
so what's the answer then
well i'm not sure i mean i'm not sure if
the furlough ending is going to make a
difference but um i don't think people
seem to realize that
and the jobs that are actually out there
you know there's jobs for
working in shops there's jobs um
delivery driving there's jobs in um
warehouses there's every job going at
the moment so
if anyone is wanting a job at the moment
now's the kind of time to be going
because they're everywhere and people
take you on today
what's the problem okay is it that um
brits don't want those jobs or is it
that there's just so many jobs that that
can't be filled or is it that because of
brexit a lot of europeans went home and
are not coming back
i don't know i mean i think i think it's
a mixture you know there's people there
who want to work who really want to go
out to work and just can't because of
problems either with child care or at
home or physical problems and i do think
there are people out there who could
work
and who maybe don't want to work
and there are i think brexit has has
made a difference and within the likes
of you know some uh delivery drivers
and
there's also our linen company where we
get all our linen from they had they
said they had quite a lot of polish
staff working there uh they haven't got
them now so
for them now they can only deliver one
day a week they can't you they can't
and provide the service they want to
provide because they haven't got the
stuff to do so i think it's a big
mixture it's not it's i don't think it's
one thing to blame and it's just a
mixture of everything altogether
and anecdotally what do your customers
say now when they come in and have a
pint as far as brexit is concerned those
that voted in favor and indeed those uh
who voted uh to stay within the european
union do they still have the same views
some have said yes and some have said
they didn't realize the impact it would
maybe have
and and
yeah it's just a case of let's see what
happens but at the moment
people really don't realize how hard it
is for every single industry out there
at the moment everyone is working so
hard there is no staff anywhere
and it's really really hard at the
moment
okay keep your head up kate thanks very
much
thank you
thanks a lot my next guest went from
working in factories and sleeping in
cars
to become the first and only ufc world
champion while fighting with one eye
as well as his world champion title
michael bisping has also starred in
hollywood blockbusters and penned a
best-selling book and now he's going on
tour across the uk pleased to say that
michael is with us now live i think from
hello hello to you mike from la i should
say hello to michael thanks for joining
us on the program you were inducted i
believe into the ufc hall of fame back
in 2019 did you ever imagine when you
started that that's where you would find
yourself
never in a million years and a pleasure
to speak to you okay yeah it's been
quite a long goal journey and there you
summed it up pretty well though you know
working in the factories sleeping in my
car and of course as you mentioned
losing an eye along the way and yeah i
never thought it would come to this but
uh here we are it's almost midnight here
in los angeles but i'm uh i just got out
of bed actually i set my alarm it's it
sounds very very rock and roll but uh
i'm old these days i got three kids i
went to bed i set my alarm and it's a
pleasure to talk to you well you look
fantastic i wish i looked like that when
i just woken up um talk to me about how
you lost your eye
well listen you know i mean the sport i
take part in it's uh you know it's a
beautiful sport but it's also very
vicious and of course it's mixed martial
arts so you know you can punch kick knee
and elbow and unfortunately i got kicked
in the head of a guy down in brazil
called vito belfort who uh was on every
performance enhancing drug under the sun
and sadly that caused my retina to
detach i got it fixed it redetached so
on and so forth six surgeries later and
sadly yeah you know i've got one eye but
still in the land of the blind the
one-eyed man is king that's what they
say but how challenging does it make you
fighting when you've only got one eye
because it must be such a big difference
that you have to get used to
yeah just a little bit you know people
always say to me how did you fight with
one eye and i always say with great
difficulty you know obviously the depth
perception is way off in fact it's
non-existent so it was very very
difficult but uh fortunately i had some
very patient coaches and uh you know we
managed to get the job done the thing
was the hardest part was keeping it
secret this whole time because obviously
you know uh getting licensed with one
eye isn't very very easy so uh i'd sell
a few porcupies along the way but still
i'm retired now so now i can start
telling the truth
and now you can tell some stories on
tour tell us about that
yeah that's right yeah so i did a
one-man show a couple of years ago in
toronto and uh if you've ever seen the
mike tyson one-man show on disputed
truth i guess it's something like that
however i didn't squander 400 million
dollars or go to prison for rape so uh
it's not too similar i guess in that
regard but still yeah so i did it in
toronto and uh everyone really enjoyed
it it was a real good laugh and then
some promoters that i got talking to you
know they
they came to me with an offer and i'm
doing a mini tour throughout the uk and
the support was so great that's actually
i'm coming back next year we're doing uh
way more dates in england we're doing
mainland europe we're doing australia
new zealand so uh it's kind of taking on
a life of its own but i'm very excited
fortunately the ufc has a really
passionate fan base in the uk and ticket
sales have been tremendous there is some
still available though so if anyone's
doing anything next week in birmingham
london manchester or glasgow get
yourself to ticket.com you can come
along and then enjoy the fun that's a
big plug uh michael
why why are you in l.a why are you not
here
uh well well the weather believe it or
not
i do miss the rain but said no my wife's
australian and uh the ufc predominantly
you know it's an american sport and i
had the work visa and my wife uh you
know she wasn't too keen on the reign so
uh we came out here just to do some
training camps but we've got three
children and uh one's twenty one's
nineteen and one's eleven and now we've
been here for ten years uh it's kind of
home for them and i i wanna come back to
england all the time but my wife would
never dream of leaving the kids and uh
yeah she doesn't wanna go back to the
rain so i miss it dearly but uh it is
what it is okay well you're coming back
to tour um and you you gave a very good
plug to what you're up to next week it's
good to talk to you thanks for getting
up especially to talk to us we really
appreciate it maybe you can catch up
with us when you're over here in the uk
next thanks a lot
my pleasure kay i'll go back to bed now
take care great talking to you sleep
tight my
the bedbugs don't bite